Speaker 1: Today we are going to be speaking
to another 2022 candidate and we will be speaking
with Republican Alison Haden.
Alison Haden is running for Congress in California's
14th District against Eric Swalwell, the current
Democratic congressman from California's 15th
congressional district, now running in the
14th due to redistricting.
Alison, it's great to have you on.
I really appreciate your time.
Speaker 5: Good morning.
Hi.
Speaker 1: So indulge me if if you will, because
there are such diverse views about this among
Republican candidates running.
I've been starting with what may be a simple
question, and if it is, that's great and we
can move on.
Who is currently the president of the United
States?
Speaker 5: Joe Biden.
Speaker 1: Okay.
And do you believe that his presidency reflects
the will of the people as they voted in 2020?
Speaker 5: I doubt it.
I don't know.
Speaker 1: You don't know where you doubt
it?
Speaker 5: I would say with so much controversy
around election integrity, which is actually
my first, I think, mandate when I get in is
really to clean up our election processes
that there are there are too many questions.
It's really not for me to I'm not on the inside
of that.
So.
Speaker 1: Well, you did retweet a meme that
says Trump won.
So it seemed something made you believe that
that you do know who actually won.
Right.
So you tweeted a meme that says Trump won.
What makes you think Trump won?
Speaker 5: Well, you know, I live in northern
California and so many people, even Democrats,
told me they voted Trump.
So the numbers didn't seem to reflect my experience.
Speaker 1: And so some Democrats told you
this.
Speaker 5: Is my you know.
Yeah.
In my own interactions with people.
Speaker 1: I mean, Trump did get 6 million
votes.
So certainly you could have been talking to
some of those 6 million.
That's not really evidence of fraud, is it?
Speaker 5: No, I'm not.
I will say I went in and I was an observer
in the processing of votes.
And there were big problems with that.
Like what?
And I even called out.
I. I witnessed.
A vote being called for.
Newsome that I could clearly see was not Newsome
on the ballot.
Speaker 1: Okay.
But in terms of you tweet, you tweeted that
Trump won.
You tweeted that Trump won.
What do you have to believe that?
Speaker 5: Election integrity.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
Speaker 5: So I think there are questions
with the vote and a need for for everyone.
You know, that's that's the basis of our Constitution
is the sovereignty of the people.
Speaker 1: Fair?
Absolutely.
Speaker 5: It be the first and foremost, you
know.
Concern on every American heart that that
that.
Be assured I'm.
Speaker 1: With you 100%.
I'm with you 100%.
Now, when I see the numbers and I say, you
know, there are so many more Democrats in
California than Republicans that we know from
voter registration.
And Joe Biden won California by 5 million
votes.
You tweeted that Trump won, but it's because
a few Democrats you spoke to said they voted
for Trump.
That that sounds weak a little bit, doesn't
it, Alison?
Speaker 5: No.
Well, you know what?
When you have a vote, that is perhaps a compromise.
So are the registrations actually anything
electronic?
We need to run through all the voter rolls
because there are you know, we don't really
know what's real.
So.
Speaker 1: So you think even the voter registration
is inaccurate?
Speaker 5: Veracity of what is being touted
as, you know, representative of Republicans
or Democrats.
But let me just say from the outset, David,
that I am not a waving a party banner.
I think that Americans are hurting.
This is not the election or the time in America
to be caring about political party membership.
I think that I rejected the Republican Party
endorsement.
I want to.
Represent Republican values that made this
country strong.
And those that's what I care about.
So I want to clean up the vote and voter rolls
because that that is, you know, the voice
of the people is what represents this country's
freedoms.
And, you know, we have to get to the bottom
of that.
We do.
Speaker 1: But I guess the issue I'm having,
Alison, and this is why I'm so interested
in talking to you is.
If you want to be taken seriously on that,
it seems as though some of the things you're
repeating on your Twitter don't really make
it so that someone would take you seriously.
I'll give you another example.
Yesterday, you retweeted a meme indicating
that 25,000 dead people voted in Michigan.
That's been looked at that that's just not
true.
Why why would you retweet that if you're so
serious about this?
Speaker 5: You know, Twitter for me is as
much about raising awareness and about people
really rethinking all of these things.
Because, you know, again, I saw that actually
today.
I just saw that the secretary of State, Benson,
had voted to keep 26,000 dead people on on
the voter rolls.
So we have problems.
Okay.
That's the long and short of it.
And Twitter I use as education and to bring
awareness and to bring discussion, we need
to have discourse about it.
And it ferrets out more information.
You know, when you throw things into the public
square, I this whole notion of discourse,
this is what is lost in America and this is
what made us strong iron.
Speaker 1: But Alison, I'm sorry.
I hate to interrupt, but you're going so off
track.
Do you know how many dead people do you believe
voted in Michigan?
Speaker 5: You know, I again, I'm not on the
inside.
I could not speak to that question.
Speaker 1: So how did you why were you comfortable
retweeting.
Speaker 5: Some for us to all look at the
voter rolls?
I don't know if you've seen any of Dr. Douglas
Franks.
Into his act.
She's been going around the country showing
us what he discovered and he's done just on
public information and watching.
And he has the voter rolls for the last 20
years.
Speaker 1: He's potentially criminally in
possession of voting machines and is being
investigated by the FBI.
I don't know that that Douglas Frank is the
person I would look to on this.
But in the.
Speaker 5: Infrastructure, the FBI is where
I would look to for for confidence either.
Speaker 1: Oh, you mean, are you a supporter
of law enforcement?
Speaker 5: You know, I am, definitely.
But you know what we have I think what's been
exposed in America is its underbelly.
And we have many problems across many institutions.
And this is the hour to clean up America,
not to shore up anything that has has fallen.
You know, when you have humans, leading institutions,
you can expect that there's going to, you
know, eventually things get corrupted.
And we have seen how many of these institutions
that we have counted on, relied on, have that
have problems.
And as much as the voter rolls, same with
the intelligence agencies we need to and law
enforcement.
I live in Alameda.
There are there is by the sheriff's office
itself admitting how corrupt things have become.
So, you know, instead of trying to defend
something, let's all come together, unite
to fix it.
Speaker 1: The problem is our.
Speaker 5: System is for the American people.
This is not about party politics.
Speaker 1: It's very wishy washy to insist
on coming together to fix things without being
able to demonstrate that they need fixing.
And I'll give you an example.
There is no evidence whatsoever that anyone
other than Joe Biden easily won in California.
There is no evidence at all that the voter
rolls in California are off.
There is no evidence that dead people voted
in Michigan.
There is no evidence that the FBI investigation
of Mike Pillow and Frank that you mentioned
is anything other than a completely legal
and well-established investigation.
It's very easy to just say, let's just come
together and we let's just let's just fix
it.
But when you're wanting to fix things without
being able to provide proof that they're broken,
it doesn't feel like it's a good faith position.
Speaker 5: When people are in control of what
is said to be true or not, and they themselves
are the corrupt ones, we don't know.
So your claims coming from them, from from
people in positions who themselves may be
the ones.
Speaker 1: That are not making claims?
Speaker 5: Well, you're saying.
Speaker 1: I'm saying you're you're making
the claim.
You're making the claim and showing no evidence
about.
Speaker 5: I'm sorry.
Speaker 1: You're making the claims.
Extraordinary claims and providing no evidence.
Speaker 5: America is shouting for truth in
voting.
Okay.
The confidence of the American voter is completely
eroded.
And we need to fix it.
We need to shore up everyone's confidence.
And that's Democrats, Republicans, every every
political stripe.
Americans are Americans.
And we stand here and our borders are impacted
because the world wants to come here and live
and to have the freedoms that we possess.
All right.
And it is our duty as Americans to make sure
those freedoms ours are stand strong.
And we we need to do that and not try to defend
something we can't win.
If there is no problem, what's the problem?
Speaker 1: That's that's my question to you.
Listen, let me let me ask you something else,
Alison, because I know, you know, we want
to focus on evidence.
You tweeted that Antifa rioters were actually
the ones breaking into the Capitol on January
6th and that MAGA Patriots were trying to
pull them away from going into the building.
You don't honestly believe that now, do you?
Speaker 5: I'm not sure.
I tweeted that.
Speaker 1: You did.
You tweeted that.
You tweeted it.
January 8th, 2021.
We can provide the citation.
Speaker 5: Where there were provocateur.
Well, I mean, please tell me that tweet.
I would love to see it.
Sure.
I mean, I tweet a lot of things, but do you.
Speaker 1: Mean the things you tweet.
Speaker 5: Were provoked?
There were provocateurs there and they were
in the crowd and they were you know, Ray Epps
was Oath Keepers.
He's known to be an FBI associated person.
There is.
Speaker 1: Absolutely no evidence that raps
as an FBI associated person.
Speaker 5: Not the four over the night before.
Speaker 1: And that has been completely debunked.
Alison.
That's been completely different.
Alison, do you mean the things you tweet?
Speaker 5: As I said, I used tweets also to
it to get people to talk about subjects which
are not settled.
We need to clean up America.
Speaker 1: Alison Do you believe that the
700.
Speaker 5: Going on, David, would you not
want it sorted out?
I would not want those.
I would brought to justice.
Speaker 1: Is there any evidence whatsoever
that you have that the 700 Trumpist defendants
from the Capitol riots were not genuinely
Trumpists?
Any evidence?
Speaker 5: Well.
Do you have any evidence they weren't?
Speaker 1: Yes.
Their social media records, their social media
histories, the things that law enforcement
found in their homes, their communications,
their overt statements about their political
views.
We have we have all of that.
Do you have anything to suggest that none
of.
Speaker 5: The people went to Washington on
January six because they questioned the vote?
That's telling you that there are many Americans
who are not comfortable with the way it went
down.
Speaker 1: But my question was, do you have
any evidence that they're not really Trumpists?
Alison, hold on.
Hold on a second.
You're answering questions, different questions.
Do I told you why?
I believe they are Trumpists went there?
Speaker 5: No, they dragged out things.
You can put a different frame on any evidence.
Speaker 1: Not a frame by frame.
Hold on a second.
Speaker 5: Anybody can you can.
You can paint a picture that is completely
divorced from reality by cherry picking evidence.
Speaker 1: So is it cherry picking to say
that the rioters had exclusively pro-Trump
social media history?
Speaker 5: Look, a grandmother is there in
jail.
People that just cared and they showed up
and they dragged those people before.
So this is not okay.
This is not America.
Those people have a right to it.
First Amendment to to confront their government
when they have a question.
Speaker 1: But wait a second, Allison.
Hold on a second.
Wait a second.
Alisyn.
Alisyn, hold on a second.
No, you first said.
Hold on a second.
Alisyn, wait a second.
Wait a second.
Nobody's going to be able to hear you unless
we can each take a turn.
You first said you don't believe they were
really maga trump people and now you're saying
they are.
Hold on.
Let me finish the question.
Speaker 5: In my mouth.
Please don't feed things into my mouth.
Everyone out there had I don't I can't characterize
I don't know them.
I've never met those 700 people.
I can't tell you what they were or were not,
but they were out there, made the trip because
they were concerned about the vote.
Speaker 1: So you agree that they were Trumpists?
Speaker 5: That doesn't make you a Trumpists.
That makes you an American concerned about
the sovereignty of your vote.
Speaker 1: Almost no Democrats were concerned
about the election.
Speaker 5: I'm sorry.
That makes you an American.
Speaker 1: Wow.
Alison, you know, you sound this completely
disconnected from reality, right?
Like completely disability.
Speaker 5: Certainly your reality.
Speaker 1: The empirical one for which we
have evidence.
Speaker 5: No, there's nothing more empirical
to yours than mine.
Real.
You have no right to.
To all of a sudden stand on a high horse.
Speaker 1: There's no horse here.
No zebra, no nothing.
You know, Alison, when you asked me what makes
me believe something, the difference, Alison,
is when you ask me.
When you ask me what makes.
Speaker 5: But that's just.
Speaker 1: No, hold on a second.
But, Alison, wait a second.
Let's see if I can get a word in edgewise.
Alison, when you ask me why I hold a certain
belief, I give you the evidentiary reasons
why.
When I ask you why you hold a belief.
You told me, well, we don't know or you answer
a different question.
You you never provide any evidence.
Do you see the difference between my beliefs
and yours?
Speaker 5: You're claiming evidence.
The evidence is.
Is the people that showed up.
Okay.
That's evidence to the.
Speaker 1: Trumpist, right?
That showed up and rioted because they were
mad.
Speaker 5: You know what?
People showed up at the Capitol.
Right.
Because the president said if you have questions,
you come out, be an American.
This was not to raid the Capitol.
Speaker 1: Which they did, though.
But they did that.
Speaker 5: You know what?
There were infiltrators there.
Speaker 1: So the rioters were not the Trumpists
who were concerned about the vote.
Is that right?
Speaker 5: I am not a person that was is able
to make any determination about the people.
All I know is that there were infiltrators
there that were whipping people up and and
trying to get things.
Wow.
So.
Speaker 1: Alison, you're scaring me.
I'm scared for the future of our nation.
Speaker 5: Really, genuinely.
And we should be.
That's.
That's what this is all about.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
No, I mean, if if folks were to vote for you,
I would be very scared.
Speaker 5: We should have fear about this.
This is why we need to get to the bottom of
it.
Yeah.
This is exactly the reason this does save
America.
This is not Trump or anything else.
Speaker 1: All right.
Well, you've heard it here from Alison Haden.
Speaker 5: Trump.
It's not about Trump.
It's about America.
Speaker 1: Your choices in the 14th District.
Speaker 5: And the right.
Speaker 1: Your choices in the 14th District
are Alison Hayden and Eric Swalwell.
That election will be just weeks away.
Alison, we're going to be watching that race
very closely.
Speaker 5: Thank you.
Thank you very much.